it was supposed to be a summer of fun
and camaraderie 36 000 Scouts mostly
teenagers for more than 150 countries in
one campsite the world Scout Jamboree
kicked off in South Korea's Bowen County
last week but participants are now
having to pack and leave
they're being moved to 128 accommodation
sites across the country ahead of
typhoon Canon's projected arrival on
Thursday officials insist however the
event isn't over
it will go on for the remaining five
days and four nights so rest assured the
participants will still be able to have
the Jamboree experience the national and
local governments will work together to
ensure that they remain safe and go home
with happy hearts
but a number of Scouts had already been
unhappy even before there was any threat
of a typhoon participants from the
United Kingdom and the United States
have been in Seoul for days the first is
the sanitation we were concerned that
the toilets weren't being cleaned
frequently enough there wasn't soap in
there and it wasn't safe and there was
rubbish building up as well South
Koreans have also criticized organizers
for a lack of foresight the country has
been battling both scorching heat and
torrential rains in the past few months
more than 40 were killed by floods and
landslides last month
given the current weather and situation
in our country these aspects weren't
taken into consideration earlier I saw
many Scout passing by they came a long
way just for things to fall through
officials have assured new
accommodations will be safe cleaned and
comfortable
but given the challenges of having to
move thousands of foreigners attending a
global event people here are also
worried about the damage it could cost
to the country's image
since we are trying to secure a major
events in Busan and foreigners will be
coming I'm ashamed that their perception
of our country might change as a Korean
I also feel somewhat sorry for them
South Korea is no stranger to holding
big events having hosted both the
Olympics and football's World Cup Busan
its second major city is vying for the
2030 World Expo with hopes setbacks at
this year's World Scout Jamboree won't
hurt its chances
Barn below Al Jazeera
foreign